sí absolutamente y eso se ve claramente
primero en los números que nosotros
tenemos en argentina tanto de infectados
como de fallecidos y segundo en el plan
de vacunación que definitivamente en la
argentina ha sido un fracaso y sigue
siendo un fracaso considerando que hoy
solamente en la argentina tenemos 13
millones de personas vacunadas
completamente es decir con dos dosis de
la vacuna a la argentina compro vacunas
de 2 dosis por lo tanto con esquema
completo de vacunación y con protección
contra esta infección hay solamente 13
millones de personas que están
inmunizadas al resto aún no y continúa
esperando por supuesto ahora ya nos dijo
entonces un panorama general de cómo
avanza la vacunación en el país que a su
criterio es lento él le pregunto
entonces en cuánto tiempo argentina va a
alcanzar una cierta inmunidad de rebaño
y qué pasa con esas personas que todavía
esperan entonces una segunda dosis de
una vacuna que todavía no ha llegado al
país por falta por falta de existencia
como lo mejor esa es la russa
si es incierto la verdad argentina es
incierto sobre todo porque la argentina
no negoció con todos los laboratorios
para comprar una solamente con algunos y
esto está en investigación también en la
argentina y por supuesto que la gente
que está esperando esas segundas dosis y
muchas otras 5 millones de personas aún
esperan la primera dosis de la vacuna
tienen una angustia muy fuerte y muy
importante por supuesto y un enojo en la
argentina que se va a traducir sin lugar
a dudas en las próximas elecciones que
nosotros tenemos por delante dentro de
una semana por lo tanto hay un clima en
la argentina de mucha atención de mucho
enojo y sobre todo de muchas personas
que tienen un descreimiento muy fuerte
en la palabra de las autoridades tanto
del presidente como de nuestra ministra
de salud que definitivamente ha hecho un
trabajo que no ha tenido buenos
resultados doctor que puede hacer el
gobierno entonces para tratar de paliar
esta crisis es cuáles pueden ser unas
buenas políticas públicas a implementar
en argentina para tratar de mejorar la
situación sanitaria del país en esta
pandemia yo creo que la primera política
pública que tiene que hacer el gobierno
argentino es pedir disculpa perdón
ustedes saben que la argentina se ha
vacunado ilegalmente a funcionarios del
gobierno este actual antes que a
pacientes de riesgo y antes que a
personal de la salud ustedes saben que
en la argentina en la quinta
presidencial donde vive el presidente se
han hecho fiestas clandestinas por lo
tanto lo primero que tiene que hacer el
gobierno argentino es pedirle disculpas
a toda su ciudadanía y a partir de ahí
definitivamente comenzar un plan de
vacunación como corresponde como se
merece cada uno de los ciudadanos
argentinos el panorama social doctor
usted también lo estaba comentando las
próximas elecciones que tanto le va a
pesar esto al gobierno del presidente
fernández le va a pesar mucho por
supuesto esto dicen las encuestas pero
sobre todo esto dice el humor social de
la gente en la calle cuando uno habla
con las personas en la calle en
argentina hay insisto un descreimiento
en la política hay enojo muy fuerte y
hay mucha gente inclusive que decide a
pesar de lo que sucede en la argentina
no ir a votar no ir a elegir a sus
futuros gobernantes por el enojo que
reina en la calle en la ciudadanía
argentina doctor gracias por su tiempo y
por supuesto por estar aquí con nosotros
en france 24